wir haben da drei problematische Aspekte
einmal sprachen sie eben vom
Bildungsauftrag den bestreitet auch
keiner aber sie empfinden ein
Erziehungsauftrag das ist ein ganz
entscheidender Unterschied ich muss die
Menschen dahin gegen bilden dass Sie
sich Ihr eigenes Urteil bilden können
und das findet nicht statt es soll von
vornherein vorgegeben sein was du zu
denken hast das ist das große Problem
aus meinem persönlichen Erfahrungsschatz
als Reporter gerade ich komme aus
Nordrhein-Westfalen der WDR der schickt
zu Pressekonferenzen vier Teams für all
das gleiche Thema nach dem Motto weil
vier verschiedene Sendung vielleicht was
wollen alleine wenn man da sieht was da
ein Geld wirklich verraten wird es ist
völlig ohne Not völlig ohne Struktur
völlig ohne Planung man geht da zwar
dran aber wirklich viel zu wenig und das
letzte und das ist das verheerendste
sind die Pensionskassen es wird jetzt
beim Programm schon gespart trotzdem
reicht das Geld nicht und genau wie
unsere Rente und irgendwann
möglicherweise um die Ohren fliegt ist
es da genauso diese Pensionskassen diese
Rentenkassen die kommen so üppige
Pension wo sich jeder fragt warum da
gibt's Ausgleichsfonds da verdient eine
Sekretärin in 10 Jahren mehr als egal
bei jedem anderen verl